A few years ago, I was in Hong Kong. I was
doing a story for Vox and I went to this
giant bridge and I flew my drone over it and it
was this big story. And a while back I was like,
does the United States have any big super
cool bridges that do all this cool stuff,
like in the ocean? Turns out we do. It's
not nearly as big, but we have this bridge,
the Chesapeake Bridge, which is four and a half
miles long. And apparently it's the scariest
bridge in America. I've driven over this bridge
a bunch because it's like 20 miles from my house,
and I never thought it was that scary. But
apparently a lot of people think it's really
scary, so much so that there's an entire service
where you could go show up with your car and there
will be someone waiting for you and they will
get in your car and they will drive you across
the bridge if you're afraid. So we have ourselves
a nice big bridge that's apparently super scary
because there's nowhere to pull off on. And if
you need to go across it, there is someone there
that will do it for you. And they've got a great
infomercial in case you need to be convinced.